eight Wisconsin teenagers are in the
hospital with severe lung damages and
doctors suspect it's from vaping
although we should point out it's not
clear what exactly they inhaled and all
this comes amid growing concerns
surrounding vaping by teens yesterday
e-cigarette maker Joule responded to
claims that it marketed its product to
young teenagers our chip Reid is on
Capitol Hill where Jools co-founder
answered questions from lawmakers chip
good morning well good morning during
two days of hearings members of Congress
heard from concerned parents teens and
jewel executives some members of
Congress accused those jewel executives
of trying to market ecigs
to young users by targeting schools by
using social media while at the same
time downplaying the dangers of e-cigs
you sir are an example to me of the
worst of the bay area you're nothing but
a marketer of a poison law makers mostly
Democrats blasted jewel co founder James
Muncie is Thursday blaming his company
for fuelling what they say is a teen
vaping epidemic we never wanted any non
nicotine user and certainly nobody
underage to ever use Joule products
Muncey's argued that jewel has taken
steps to keep ecigs away from kids
including shutting down its Facebook and
Instagram pages and pulling several of
its flavored pods from stores but that
wasn't enough for some lawmakers flavors
hook kids and though you say that you
took all the flavors out of the stores
you left the mint flavor nearly one in
five u.s. high school students reported
using e-cigs in the last month
still drool insists its goal has always
been to help adult smokers transition
from traditional cigarettes are you
concerned by the number of teenagers who
report vaping or using joules I I could
not be more concerned about that
lawmakers contend drool used big tobacco
marketing tactics by donating to youth
wellness camps offering some schools
$10,000 for anti vaping education
programs Wednesday 17-year old Caleb
Mints testified that a dual
representative spoke at his school
during a mental health and addiction
seminar
designed by the school to be attended by
students only
I believe the presenter was sending
mixed messages by saying jewel is
totally safe and following up every
totally safe statement with but we don't
want you as customers jewel says it
ended its education program in September
after its purpose was misconstrued they
said the purpose was really to warn
teens about the dangers of nicotine
addiction the FDA has not yet reviewed
the safety of e-cigs but they did this
month month-long launched an ad campaign
to warn teens about vaping Galle hope
it's an ongoing conversation chip thank
you very much